que gsm pierrât docteur en communication
politique bonsoir je laissais ma pierre
à merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france on a écouté emmanuel macron
tout à l'heure en direct sur notre
antenne de s'exprimer après sa vision
conférence avec les 27 dirigeants de
l'union européenne l'union européenne
qui doit rester uni selon lui comment
vous l'avez trouvé son discours plutôt
rassurant il a beaucoup parlé de la
crise économique un qu'il souhaite
freiner avec les autres pays
oui emmanuel macron doit impérativement
devenir le leader d'un combat contre une
crise assez grave une guerre sanitaires
c'est bien évidemment une virose
respiratoires beaucoup plus grave que
les grippes saisonnières
mais il y a quatre plans qui sont à mon
avis déterminant nous devons absolument
corps dîner organisé être les leaders
pour organiser la coordination
pharmaceutique mondial a
exceptionnellement à caractère
désintéressé
on doit aussi les autorités de tutelle
ont serré la vis aux hôpitaux il faut
des serrer la vis et lâché des crédits
il faut booster il a raison de le faire
ce soir
elles sont fines et les organisations
européennes et la recherche
il faut faire une passerelle européenne
via chinoise mais ses quatre plans sont
déterminants pour donner des solutions à
un peuple qui est extrêmement angoissés
et en psychose notamment en province
alors emmanuel macron il est partout
tous les jours on le voit en direct sur
les chaînes
d'infos tantôt dans un épatant toi
l'hôpital necker ce matin c'est ce qu'on
attend de lui
vous pensez que une marque des points
président de la république électorat sur
en se montrant comme ça devant la la la
france a à une grosse légitimité parce
qu'on a un très gros potentiel au niveau
pharmaceutique au niveau virologie je
vous rappelle que pasteur c'est le
premier laboratoire au monde donc je
crois que oui
il devrait même encore aller plus loin
pour prendre ce leader de de travailler
ensemble au niveau européen au niveau
mondial parce que vend au niveau de
l'onu de l'om ces deux-là de la bce bon
on n'entend pas grand chose donc on est
un petit peu éberlués que toutes ces
institutions sont presque paralysée par
leur taille et leurs aspects théoriques
là on a besoin de concret on a besoin de
leaders et aujourd'hui ce peuple de
france qui en état de psychose voire de
choc psychologique
il est c'est comme un phénomène de foule
il est plus en état de d'entendre de la
rationalité il est complètement dans
l'irrationalité il a besoin de tangible
il a besoin de concret il a besoin qu'on
lui explique de pédagogie et qu'on lui
dise comment va s'en sortir mais
j'espère à vous parler de la
coordination avec toutes ces grandes
institutions on a le sentiment
d'ailleurs cette visioconférence ans
c'était plus pour réagir à ce krach
boursier et hier enfin en tout cas ce
lundi noir sur sur les marchés on a le
sentiment que les états gèrent en
fonction de l'importance de l'épidémie
sur leur territoire la leur façon de
faire c'est compliqué de tout coordonner
au niveau monde alors effectivement on
peut se coordonner sur la recherche d'un
vaccin sûr voilà sur les moyens mais
vous voyez bien que à nos portes hier
l'italie qui est dans une situation
assez délicate
ça n'est pas la même qu'en france ça
doit plus être compliqué en politique
c'est décidé en politique c'est la
volonté dont qui il est il est très
important de combattre toutes ces
paralysies tous et immobile
sme et je pense que la france comme je
le disais non seulement à légitimité
mais il a l'énergie il a la volonté
il doit pouvoir à arriver à coordonner
les recherches les avancées en
pharmaceutique
il doit il doit pouvoir le faire et en
france on s'en sort tant bien que mal
mais on a quand même une très belle
infrastructure hospitalière d' analyses
de laboratoire et c'est aujourd'hui pour
vous justement
les hôpitaux français semblent prêts à
accueillir cette crise épidémique les
hôpitaux font un travail remarquable
tous ceux qui sont passés par les
hôpitaux une fois dans leur vie
bon savent à quel point ils sont dévoués
ils sont compétents et bon comme je vous
le disais en préambule les autorités de
tutelle en trop serrer la vis donc
aujourd'hui il faut il faut relâcher des
moyens il faut aller écouter faut voir
un peu de quoi ils ont besoin et
immédiatement dans le concret il faut
sortir des discours académique et comme
général qui a commandé deux guerres je
les manuels macron doit absolument
devenir ce général dans cette guerre
sanitaires et il doit interroger vous
avez besoin de quoi on s'y prend comme
ans quel calendrier etc
on doit être dans le concret pas dans
des discours académique
alors le président de la république est
peut-être comme vous le dites dans un
discours académique son ministre de la
santé olivier veyrat directeur général
de la santé 1 jérôme salomon vous les
trouvez comment ces assurances et point
quotidien cette litanie
du nombre de cas du nombre de décès en
france à ce qu'on doit en passer par là
olivier ferrand arrive il ya peu de
temps ils récupèrent la situation de
madame bus d'un bon c'est pas facile
il a beaucoup de volonté il a beaucoup
d'énergie et la situation et est assez
inédite donc mais je rappelle quand même
qu'il est médecin
donc il y là il a tout pour réussir au
poste où il est aujourd'hui
ces mesures les rassemblements de plus
de 1000 personnes interdit les matchs de
foot les matelots enfin de d'ailleurs
tous les sports qui se joue à huis clos
ça vous semble être des bonnes solutions
vous pour endiguer cette épice faut
absolument éradiquer ce virus donc peu
importe aujourd'hui qu'on qu'on arrête
un peu cette vie sociale cette vie
collective
l'important c'est d'arriver à se sortir
de cette situation sanitaire dramatique
qui touche déjà beaucoup de familles ce
soir il ya 1700 et quelques cas et donc
on peut plus raisonner en termes comme
ça de contrariété d'affect et compagnie
il faut il faut absolument pour trouver
les moyens
je vous le dis c'est vraiment avec les
les laboratoires roche sanofi merck
l'aco beyer johnson and johnson faut
absolument que quelqu'un prenne l'élan
le leader de ca et 10 bon maintenant on
sort des logiques d'intérêt parce que la
vie vaut mieux que l'économie l'économie
viendra après et je vous le rappelle
michel attendant toujours âprement
l'économie elle est basée sur la
confiance s'il n'y a plus confiance il
ya tout qui s'écroule
donc aujourd'hui il faut restaurer la
confiance
alors c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup
d'économies regard oui on les bourses
qui se sont écroulés voile avec les
politiques réagissent m'enfin derrière
les bourses ya aussi des entreprises qui
sont subventionnées d
des pme y avoir là il n'y a pas que les
grenats grand finances la haute finance
c'est quand même un vrai problème
aujourd'hui dit qu'il faut abandonner
cette vie sociale enfin d'arrêter j'ai
eu tout à l'heure des personnes dans le
haut rhin qui me disait vas tous les
hôtels sont en train de fermer dans le
haut rhin c'est quand même très embêtant
pour tous ces secteurs qui sont en péril
il s'agit pas d'être naïf il s'agit pas
d'être trop optimiste mais je crois que
l'économie reprendra l'économie elle a
deux mamelles
elle a la confiance et l'imagination
l'économie va reprendre
comme à chaque fois qu'il ya des guerres
qu'elle soit autrement ou qu'elle soit
sanitaires on trouvera des solutions
on fera avancer cette économie ça c'est
ça vient après aujourd'hui c'est le
combat pour la vie le combat pour la
survie et éradiquer totalement ce virus
arrivé à comprendre les cellules souches
arriver à comprendre comment on va
trouver des médicaments peut-être un
vaccin et croiser tous les savoirs et
arrêter la course aux brevets la course
aux intérêts il ya un intérêt général
qui est en jeu c'est quand même une
situation assez inédite et est donc
c'est ça qui la primauté l'économie
viendra après ça reviendra en tout cas
on ne parle plus que de cela le
coronavirus
le projet de réforme des retraites est
passée avec le 49-3 on n'en parle plus
c'est commode pour le gouvernement
sans vouloir faire du cynisme le 49-3
vous savez bond a été adopté il y à peu
il va partir au sénat
au sénat il va y avoir une discussion et
ensuite il revient à la banque pour
l'instant je crois que tout est un petit
peu pas autre parenthèse mais un peu
tendu suspendu parce que bon les
municipales dans tout ça on est en
pleine campagne premier tour le 15 mars
1 dimanche prochain 28 % des français
qui ne veulent pas aller voter en raison
du risque d'épidémie ont ils dit est-ce
qu'on aurait dû repousser ces
municipales il ya beaucoup de meetings
qui se tiennent pas également
c'est un rendez vous démocratique majeur
et je crains bien qu'il y ait une grosse
abstention et donc ces municipales je
pense que j'aurais préféré qu'elle soit
reportée
aujourd'hui on va voir quelle et
comportements mais vous avez vu à paris
la vie continue il ya beaucoup de monde
partout dans les rues donc il ya aussi
une intelligence situationnelle des gens
les les français sont très réactifs et
du coup on va voir comment se passe ce
premier enjeu du vote des municipales où
tout et tout et en point d'interrogation
merci en tout cas j'ai scène pierre à
docteur en communication politique
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france